in a bid to drive voters to the polls
joe biden rolled out his most powerful
asset
speaking to a driving crowd in
philadelphia barack obama broke
the presidential code of criticizing his
successor hello philadelphia
it was a total takedown from donald
trump's taxes
to the economy packing his biggest punch
on the pandemic we literally
left this white house a pandemic
playbook
that would have shown them how to
respond
before the virus reached our shores
they probably used it to i don't know
prop up a wobbly table somewhere we
don't know where that playbook went
barack obama still has huge pull here
people queueing for hours to hear him
speak
nearly four and a half million obama
supporters didn't turn out for hillary
last time
and joe biden needs them you know i
think that biden really can do it i
think we're coming together and i think
we're getting more and more momentum
like i finally feel like i can go to
sleep at night
because i think it's really happening i
feel like he can do it i feel like he
can rile everybody up and i feel like he
can win it
having barack obama here kicking off the
day uh to start the campaign off here in
philly
i think this is major right here it's
little surprise barack obama has chosen
pennsylvania as his first campaign
appearance donald trump won
by a razor thin margin here in 2016
and it's widely regarded as the tipping
point in this election
whoever wins pennsylvania will likely
win the white house
in another battleground north carolina
donald trump
addressed voters at another packed rally
but with less than two weeks to go an
unwelcome warning
in an unusual press conference from the
fbi
over election interference first
we have confirmed that some voter
registration information
has been obtained by iran and separately
by russia this data can be used by
foreign actors
to attempt to communicate false
information
to registered voters that they hope will
cause
confusion so chaos and
undermine your confidence in american
democracy
as the fbi seeks to reassure voters and
the two candidates prepare to face
each other in the last presidential
debate
the stakes could not be higher sally
lockwood sky news philadelphia